[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Deb in Texas Deb
writes I've always tried to be organized
with my finances my husband on the other
hand never had any control on spending
we've been married for 16 years and I
just discovered he had a Best Buy credit
card balance of ten thousand dollars wow
the same card he hid from me two years
ago after arguing every day he finally
sat down and talked about the problem we
started the baby steps in March and did
Financial Peace University with Jade I
was so happy because I started to see a
change he even cut his credit cards in
one of the classes I recently told him
that I needed to add his other bank
account to every dollar budget to keep
track and what came out of his mouth was
you have the other bank information you
have you want to have control over this
one too
once again I feel hopeless and tired I
know there are money problems and the
lack of communication will eventually
kill our marriage actually that's not
what's going to kill your marriage
it's going to kill your marriage as you
have a husband who lies to you regularly
what's going to kill your marriage is
you all have not sat down in a room with
the marriage counselor and said
the marriage we had where we trusted
each other where you weren't trying to
be in control of everything and y'all
were Partners in this thing and he was
honest and was a partner in this thing
as well
that we that's over and we have to
rebuild it y'all haven't done that
and so what you're doing is blaming
money what you're doing is blaming the
lack of communication those are symptoms
of two people not on the same page
and so
um
Rachel this marriage is in car Isis and
this is a Turn All the Lights On turn
the music off we're going to counseling
right now because we have to decide if
we want to stay married or not yep
it's one of those things that you know
when you fix just the symptom and you
don't fix what's really going on it's
going to Bubble Up right so like and
that's what's happening it's like okay
well we fixed that he cut up the credit
card which is great
but understanding we talk about this a
lot on the show is that yeah your money
problems aren't usually money problems
it's usually marriage problems and so
the fact either couples are like yep
you're right we're gonna sign page cut
the credit card and we're in this
together right so this story could have
been oh yeah we need the other account
for everyone absolutely yeah yeah here
it is and you keep trucking right
there's a there's a level of healing and
just the sense of we're on the we're in
this together and you are but when
statements like this arise and you can
start to see oh my gosh she doesn't he
doesn't trust me he doesn't want me to
see something
then you know underneath all of that it
hasn't been fixed and it may not even be
that he's doing something nefarious it
may mean
maybe you are overbearing maybe you are
in his business about every second of
everything and maybe he is being
dishonest because he feels genuine like
who knows what the issue is right
um more than likely he's hiding things
and lying to you right
um but whatever it is you have to get to
the bottom of that
um and what does that sound like in real
life let's just get brass tacks that
sounds like I will not be married to
somebody who continues to lie to my face
and put my family's financial future at
risk period
I will not be married to somebody who
hides money from me and from our kids
and who will not be in alignment with me
right I mean that's what we're talking
about here yeah and um I've said this
before and I'll say it again I think
that
Fidelity we talk about that cheating if
you will we only talk about that in a
did you hook up with somebody you're not
married to context yeah I think you can
cheat on your spouse with your hobbies
you can cheat on your spouse by working
100 hours a week 160 hours a week you
can cheat with alcohol you can be a
person who is not does not have Fidelity
in a relationship with a bunch of
different things yes yes and financial
infidelity is one of those things yep
absolutely and sadly it's one that we
see I mean not crazy often but enough
to know okay there's stuff that that is
broken here and marriage is hard right I
mean stuff so hard always it's stuff
that you're working on but I think the
the point of bringing in a third party
even at this point
um for for Deb is what I what I would
encourage because obviously you guys are
trying to do this on your own which is
you know honorable but also to be able
to get to the root issue I think having
somebody to walk you through that ask
the right questions pinpoint The Right
Stuff
um is really crucial here's a good
analogy if you've been fixing your roof
for 16 years and it still leaks every
time it rains call a roofer yeah you
aren't getting the job done yeah for
whatever reason you don't have the
skills you don't have expertise whatever
you are not able to solve this problem
get a roofer you've been working on your
marriage for 16 years you've tried
programs you've tried shame we've tried
yelling you've tried uh arguments every
day you tried all these things you're
hiding money from each other it's not
working get a professional